[موسيقى]
لماذا
ظهر لماذا ظهر التنوير في القرن الثامن
عشر انا اقفز من القرن السادس عشر الى
الثامن عشر
لماذا ظهرت التنوير في اوروبا
وهي ايجاد علاج للمجازر المذهبيه
والطائفيه في اوروبا مثلا مجزره
مثلا المجازر اخرى كثيره الحروب المذهبيه
هي التي دفعتها
اوروبا الى
بلوره سهم جديد للتراث المسيحي بالها ونحن
الان ايضا نعاني من من الحروب مذهبيه من
التطرف
نعانيات وبالتالي هون في تشابهم ما بين
الحادث الاوروبيه قبل القرنين او ثلاثه
والحاله الاسلاميه والعربيه الان هناك
تشابه هناك
[موسيقى]
يا اخي الكريم هو الذي حصل هو انفجارات
همم لن يرافقها او لم يسبقها على عكس
التجارب الاوروبي ثورات الاوروبي سبقها
تدوير فكري تنوير ديلي
ولذلك اعطت وكلها اعطت ثمارها في حين انه
الانتفاضات العربيه لم يسبقها تنوير ديدي
وتنوير فلسفي ولذلك سطت عليها جماعات همم
الاخوان المسلمين
نعم او الحركه
وبالتالي وجهد ثورات انتفاضات الربيع
العربي
بسبب ان سطت عليها جماعات مضاده لحركه
التاريخ
مضاده لصاحب الدين ضد التدوير الفلسفي
مضاده ل- همم
مثلا همم
جديده للتكفير مثلا يعني جماعات معيده
للتكفير هل يمكن هل ان تصنع المستقبل لذلك
فشلت هذه
الانتفاضه لذلك انا اقول جعل للربيع
العربي اذا سوف يحصل مستقبلا ولكن بعد ان
يحصل الربيع الفكري بعد ان يحصد التدوير
الفكري بعد ان ننتقل من لاهوت التكثير الى
داهود التنوير
[موسيقى]